an expert on dentists and reinforcement
learning is also a lot of great work
sometimes with a nice information theory
uh flavor to it but uh
i'm excited to stop this all the others
really with
please join me in welcoming daniel thank
you yeah
and thanks a lot for the invitation it's
uh great to give this talk
um one of my co-authors who's also on
the chat i think
jalaj bhandari so like the doris here he
can
answer some of these questions okay um
so this talk will be about uh
sort of have an ambitious goal of trying
to synthesize
um two pieces of work
the first is joint withdraw lodge and um
i want to
sort of give a plug that uh while an
early version of this has been out for a
while
a sort of much more thorough version was
posted to archive
yesterday so you should check that out
and the second one is is this paper that
probably fewer people have heard about
okay
so uh here's the outline
in the beginning i'll try to talk about
the sort of both pieces of work are
going to be
my attempt to um understand uh clearly
what's going on in this uh
exciting work uh around policy gradient
methods
okay so the first is going to be asking
do policy gradient methods converge to
the global optimum
and when and why okay and this is subtle
because they're directly optimizing
somehow a non-convex
multi-period objective and
uh sort of the punch line here is that
we're gonna avoid reasoning about
the multi-period objective almost
entirely and instead
study the simpler optimization problems
that are solved by policy iteration
come up with conditions that only are
are based on these one period objectives
that guarantee that policy gradient
reaches the global level
okay so think of this as some punch line
of like if the problem's well suited to
policy iteration then policy gradient
so works okay very general
now that then leads to some question of
why are we doing policy grading
okay if this was your punch line in the
first part then
what's the benefit of policy gradient
methods and
here i want to zero in on a special case
that involves the use of state
aggregated policies
where you can really say something i'm
pretty sharp and transparent
about the provable benefits of policy
grading
so here we go and feel free to stop me
at any time if there are questions
okay so some setup let's first kind of
develop some notation while recapping
what a policy iteration does
so here i will be minimizing costs
rather than maximizing values so we have
a cost to go function rather than a
value function
okay so the cost to go function i'll
denote by j
pi of s and it's the expected cumulative
discounted cost associated with
a given policy from a given initial
state
the q function or state action possible
function
measures the expected cost incurred
for a one-shot deviation from that
policy pi
where you take the action a in the
initial state and then follow pi
thereafter
so given if you kind of have already
evaluated this fixed thing
j pi this is a kind of one period
objective
over a
and it's kind of very closely related to
what you calculate when you make bellman
updates
basically the same thing now policy
iteration
solves uh produces a sequence of
policies
by in each step solving this single
period optimization problem
where it minimizes over actions
the cost it would get by taking this one
shot deviation
now this temporal decomposition in a way
breaking down a multi-period problem
into a sequence of one-period problems
is really the thing that lies at the
heart of dynamic programming
and it leverages kind of monotonicity
structure
it's present in dynamic programming to
be able to do that
and sort of the key result you get in
this sort of space
is that the cost to go goes down and
down you produce
improving policies as you run this
iteration and
often pretty rapidly the cost to goes
converge to the
optimal customer all right
so i view this as sort of the classic
way we understand dynamic programming
this sort of temporal decomposition
breaking it up into single period
problems
and as a person who then kind of teaches
uh
you know a class on this stuff it's sort
of puzzling then
trying to get your head around uh what's
done in rl
uh often these days which is instead
direct policy search
so i'll call policy iteration indirect
policy search because it's
breaking things up into these one period
problems
instead policy gradient says
well the first change is because we're
going to take gradients we need a
scalar loss function so let's let l of
pi
be the average cost incurred
when you start at a random initial start
state
okay the one minus gamma here is some
normalization that makes this sort of a
per period loss
this is something like the average cost
per period
the now we're going to search not over
all possible policies
but over a parameterized family of
policies
okay and this is encoding some inductive
bias
about the form of an effective policy
okay and in my notation here theta is a
convex set of parameters
and pi is the set of all policies
all right so what's policy gradient
it's gradient descent or stochastic
gradient descent on this
policy parameter with respect to this
loss function
l okay so if l is what we care about
and uh we sort of come from the school
of people who are used to doing gradient
descent on neural networks or something
sort of the obvious thing to do is to do
gradient descent on l
okay producing hopefully better and
better parents
okay okay so far
all right a couple of points to make
one is that for this talk i'll be
thinking about exact gradient
evaluations
i think the main subtleties about
whether this method converges to the
global optimum or not
are not really due to whether there's
noise in the gradient evaluations
the other uh sort of crucial thing um
which is a big focus of the paper but
will mostly not be a focus of the talk
is that for these methods to have
desirable convergence guarantees
we need to pick a initial distribution
row
that in a sense explores all relevant
parts of the state space
okay or essentially puts weight on all
relative relevant parts of the state
space
so i'll be a little heuristic here and
what you should imagine for this talk is
sort of that the uh the mass
assigned to each state is positive
okay if this is a discrete status
okay so there we go now what's a little
odd here from the perspective
of you know if you start with policy
iteration something that seems to work
well
at least for a broad class of problems
is that what we introduced instead was a
reduction
of the dynamic programming problem where
we search for an optimal policy
to non-convex optimization
because the loss function here
l is a multi-period objective it
involves
the cost incurred um
from selecting a policy way out into the
future
and changes to your policy can have a
compounding impact
um on the loss you incur out into the
future
due to
subtleties of which states you visit
and so it's not really clear whether
we should reach a global optimum by
doing this
and as you sort of puzzle over this you
find that there's simple examples
that say that in general we're not going
to reach the global option
okay so one thing we do in the paper is
discuss a two-state example
where the parametrized policy class has
the global optimum
the policy class is one dimensional
it's sort of as benign as you could
imagine
and policy gradient can get stuck in a
bad local moon
now basically i found this to be sort of
unsatisfying because what we wanted was
to pick a parametrized policy class that
encodes an inductive bias about the
form of an effective policy here
we picked a one-dimensional family of
policies that is good enough to contain
the optimum so we really got it right
but we can't find the optimum by local
search
well hope is not lost
so what sort of sparked uh this
investigation in particular was a paper
by faisal at all in 2018
that showed that for linear quadratic
control
problems with the class of linear
policies
policy gradient does converge rapidly to
the global okay
now so there's a case where you have a
strong inductive bias about the form of
an effective policy
you restrict to that class of policies
you optimize a non-convex objective
and you find the global option okay
now sort of separate from that there's
an older paper in
the operations literature that
comes to a similar conclusion for finite
horizon inventory control problems
with the class of base stock policies
all right and the natural thing is to
try to reconcile what's going on here
but uh fortunately to me at least both
of these papers involve
pretty intricate and careful analyses
they leverage a lot of uh kind of closed
form
arguments that you can complete in these
two cases it's not really clear
what's special about linear quadratic
control that drives global convergence
while we lose it for this simple
two-state mdv
so sort of the contribution of the first
of these two papers is to identify
some general conditions that ensure the
policy gradient loss function
has no sub-optimal stationary points
so in in unconstrained optimization a
stationary point is the point where the
gradient is zero
and you expect first order methods to
gradient descent
to make progress until they reach a
point where the gradient is zero
the objective is flat and they can't
make progress anymore
and a way to study uh convergence to the
optimum
in an algorithm independent way is to
sort of think about the landscape of
that loss function and say when you hit
a flat point
are you at the optimal level and we're
going to say that you
are at the optimum at the point where
you get stuck
for all of these four examples and for a
broader class of problems
that satisfy some some general
conditions
and those conditions are going to
clarify what's going wrong
pause here if there are questions
so here's going to be the approach this
is
kind of how the proof the proofs really
go through this this sort of approach
well i'm going to try to uh
step by step rewrite the policy the way
i think about policy iteration
until we can draw a really
crisp connection with policy gradient
and kind of uh through that crisp
connection we can avoid reasoning about
the loss function l directly at any
point
so we can avoid thinking about the
multi-period loss
you can probably hear the car alarm this
is what it is
to live in new york city during the
pandemic
okay so
the let me introduce a weighted version
of the bellman cost function okay so
instead of thinking about q for every
single s
say that if you pick a policy pi plus
that we apply for one period
and we apply pi thereafter the average
cost we incur
is this okay and this
obviously depends on how we weight the
initial states
eta is going to be some uh uh specified
weighting now policy iteration then
is can be viewed as minimizing over all
next
kind of one period policies that we
apply on this single period objective
so it does this iteratively
what's nice about including a weighting
here
is that because this is a scalar
function you could think about
minimizing it over a parameterized class
of policies
so here i'm overloading notation and
plugging in theta
instead of pi theta okay
so you could think of policy iteration
over a subclass of policies
as minimizing this weighted
bellman cost over policies
okay
now it's not usually presented in this
uh form um
and it's not how i kind of before this
project maybe would have thought about
the policy gradient theorem
but i think a nice way to think about
the policy gradient here
at least some generalizations of it is
that it tells you that the gradient of
your multi-period loss function
l is deeply connected to the gradients
of these
single period loss functions
in particular you can think of policy
gradient as
implicitly not doing anything related to
l
but instead forming a single period
policy iteration objective
and rather than solving it to optimality
it takes a single gradient
step according to that objective
given this formula
now
from that we're going to sort of skip
the reasoning about the nasty non-convex
loss function
l and think only about conditions
on this policy iteration objective
so with this two conditions on the
policy iteration objective
are going to ensure that there are no
sub-optimal stationary points
of the non-convex loss function l
the policy gradient actually tries to
optimize
okay so the first one
is that i think really the key
contribution of this work
the first condition is that the policy
class is closed
under policy improvement
so what does that mean well let's first
think about it through a special example
in linear quadratic control the natural
class of policies to optimize over
is not the class of all policies it's
the class of linear policies
either take the state which is a vector
and multiply it by a matrix
to get the action intake all right
now that's the natural class of policies
to consider because we know that the
optimum lies in that class
but actually there's a stronger property
too
which is that if you start with a linear
policy
and you apply one step of policy
iteration
you get back another linear policy
so i'll call that property closure of
the policy class
it's the class the res subclass of
policies over which we're searching
is closed under policy and it could be
written
more generally this way for any
parametrized policy the policy iteration
update could be taken
as a another parameterized policy rather
than
a policy outside your class
i'll think of this as and i guess
there's sort of a question is is this
the right sense in which the policy
class
we're selecting is sufficient for
control because we saw
way back that containing the optimal
policy
is not somehow sufficient to guarantee
conversions
the second sort of
property we need is something that makes
this
uh problem amenable to first order
methods
and here the question is basically
whether we could have solved the
single period policy iteration update
problem
from by using a first order method
so does that problem have no bad
stationary points
okay and that's kind of in these
classical control problems
very easy sometimes to ensure
okay so for linear quadratic control
this is a quadratic optimization problem
there's no issues of non-convexity and
so on and so this holds immediately
same is true for classical mdps with
finite number of states and actions
then the policy iteration problem is a
is a linear problem over the class of
uh stochastic policies
okay so that's really the the main uh
punchline of that work
i think some way of trying to clarify
what is special about certain examples
where policy gradient works and what is
uh differentiating it from bad examples
i'll just sort of plug that this is a
longer paper that kind of goes into
more detail about many in many different
directions
one is trying to infer rates of
convergence
by strengthening this
condition here
one is looking into approximation
results
and so on okay there's also a sort of a
note that gives a
geometric convergence for finite state
mdps
so sort of quickly uh touch on some
related work
uh i'd say we started this in 2019
and in the later parts of 2019 and then
especially in 2020
the policy gradient paper is kind of
poured out in the literature
um i'll just mention a few uh highlights
one is that it kind of very broadly
we're certainly
building on um key ideas that are
developed
in in earlier literature okay so
i should mention the conservative policy
duration analysis
which really lays the groundwork for a
lot of what we do
and also the closure under a bellman
update is something that has appeared in
the literature on value function
approximation
which made it sort of unnatural to ask
whether closure under policy improvement
is what's going on in the linear
quadratic control example
okay let's just sort of mention that uh
a lot of this key work including what's
with theater the force here
goes off in in different directions than
what we've done for example developing
lots of results on natural policy
gradient methods
i'd say that the kind of key
distinguishing feature in our work is
this condition here
anytime i want to push a little on this
just give you kind of a preview of what
this second bit of work does
i see that the punchline of that
first paper is that policy gradient
inherits nice structure
that makes the policy iteration problem
tractable
in a lot of different cases
but if that's the way you're reasoning
about policy gradient methods
something uh really felt unsatisfying to
me because it doesn't answer
why i am performing direct policy search
rather than the indirect policy search
of policy iteration
so this
work is trying to understand
in one special case the approximation
benefits of policy gradient methods
and i think that the um
so sort of you can uh pull out some
ideas
like that from from this paper for
example
but often without clear lower bounds and
it's often sort of by interpreting
distribution shift coefficients or
something versus what we
conjecture as possible otherwise so the
main contribution here is to have a very
crisp specific example
where we can say something sharp
okay
the crisp specific example is going to
be that of state aggregation
which is something that has a long
history in in dynamic programming
often the first paper is uh that's
mentioned is this one by ward witt
in 1978 and really
as early as people were thinking about
approximate dynamic programming they
were thinking about this
so the idea is that we can build policy
or value
approximations that don't distinguish
between states in a
common partition where we've partitioned
a say you might think of a continuous
state space
into components that we think contain
only
similar states
so i could formally write down what a
state aggregation
is as
uh okay yes as a mapping
from each state to a representative
state that
sits in this partition okay anywhere in
the partition i map to a particular
point here
state aggregated policies are policies
that don't distinguish between
states in a common partition so if the
two states get mapped to a common
representer
they take the same action here
for value functions i'll say that a
state aggregated value function
is one where if the two states get
mapped to a common representer
they get assigned the same value as long
as you pick the same action
okay so what we'll uh show here
so i i want to sort of uh clarify that
i've done some normalization here so
i've uh
scaled by one minus gamma so this is the
average
loss per period okay
and and so there's going to be a one
minus gamma that sort of gets hidden
now we're going to sort of
measure the loss you get relative to an
inherent unavoidable error
and this is going to be the smallest
number
such that for any two states
in the same partition we can say that
their value functions are close
that the value assigned to those two
states sorry is close
okay so this is the error that comes
from
collapsing a whole partition down to a
representative
now what we're going what gets proved
here
is that if you apply a policy gradient
then the limiting loss that you incur
is less than two times this inherent
error
away from the optimal
okay so somehow the inherent error
is the per period
loss that you get but under approximate
policy iteration
for example and also under approximate
value iteration so these classic
adp algorithms the
loss that you get in the limit
is the inherent error inflated by
a factor of the horizon
okay
now it's running out of time so i'll
just close
with two comments one is that the
papers spend some time trying to
understand what is going on
why is it better okay and i think that
the
critical uh uh difference
has to do with the norm in which uh
uh we're measuring things so
the policy gradient formula has here the
discounted state occupancy measure
it's somehow inherently asking
about
inherently weighting states by the
fraction of time that your policy visits
those states
it's an on policy statewide and that's
very inherent to how we
construct things in policy gradient
methods and
it's something that is not always done
in these uh
more classical approximate dynamic
programming methods
and i think more so
more than anything else that's what's
driving
this gap here and the way uh
what sort of inspired this paper was
some readings about uh provable benefits
of on policy state weightings
in uh value functions
okay so i'll close there for questions
um so i ran a little bit on time
you're just on time but uh thank you
daniel that was a great talk
one round of applause uh so before we
move on to the general discussion
section are there any
questions specifically for dan's talk
sure can i ask a question please
uh yeah like this is the last result
uh this is many things about the policy
class like you you were
talking about the convergence not
getting stuck in local optimization this
it seems like first you wanted to say
that
there is some approximation error
advantage
but then it turned into a result that
seemed to
indicate that policy gradient actually
finds
a policy that is better or that that
satisfies this better
uh header bond uh so what's going on
there because
i know that if you do state aggregation
you can forget all the states like
blind policies then the policy search
problem
that tries to find the infield is np
hard
uh well it's not clear i guess that we
found
the best possible policy in within the
uh okay so you say the state aggregated
policy
relaxation of that problem
uh makes the problem but like is there
any other assumption about the policy
class are you still assuming
the same things as you are shown in the
first part of the talk or
great so it's not closed under policy
improvement
um instead basically the set of state
aggregated policies is the set of
all stochastic policies
such that the probability distribution
over actions
is the same for all states in a common
partition
[Music]
so that's the the condition is that uh
the action distribution is the same
at any at all states in the same
partition
and that's the policy class i think
that's the only assumption
um and
the fact i guess that this limit exists
is just that you make monotonic
improvements
so you get better and better and better
because you're taking gradients
until you get stuck somewhere and
what the paper does is it asks when you
get stuck so you're at a stationary
point
how far is the stationary point
among the class of away from the best
among all possible policies
not just state aggravated policies wait
are you actually proving convergence or
or not for the policies
it's a minor like uh uh i'm proving
convergence
for the loss yeah okay
so maybe the policy started going around
around and like never come back
but the loss yeah yeah you might have to
pass to a subsequence
for that yeah
very interesting thing
uh hi uh uh i had a query uh
with respect to the um random time uh
horizon case uh what happens
in that settings
uh is it the same or
yeah that's a good question so
let me see if
you know i think it's mostly the same uh
so i actually you know one way of
viewing this kind of objective
is uh sort of
the is that there is a random horizon
but the horizon is geometrically
distributed
um so there is a one case in which this
is
sort of exactly the same my guess is
that if the time horizon is um
is random uh it's just sort of in the
episodic case
basically everything is the same
but you need sufficient conditions
on something like a
mixing time right on
basically like enough to make sure that
the bellman operators are contractions
and things like that
so i bet that for stochastic shortest
path problems or something
something like this could go through but
we haven't worked that out
okay uh yeah that
makes sense thanks
there are no more questions for dan
specifically let's please give
another virtual round of applause and uh